Democrats tied themselves to the mast on
impeachment and president from fires
back by releasing the transcript of his
call with ukrainian president i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show man
oh man a lot of news this morning so we
begin with the breaking news yesterday
which is Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of the
House announcing that she has now opened
an impeachment inquiry into the
President of the United States now what
does that mean practically the answer is
pretty much nothing there are already
several different committees in the
house that were investigating the
president now she has just put them
under the bigger umbrella of an
impeachment inquiry in fact there are
some Democrats are angry with Pelosi for
not actually having given them any
additional power to go after the
president nonetheless this does
represent a market shift in terms of
Pelosi zone position on impeachment it
is now clear that the house in all
likelihood will end up impeaching Donald
Trump the Democrats do have a majority
there they're already well over 200
Democratic Congress people who are in
favor of impeaching President Trump
Nancy Pelosi announcing yesterday that
they are moving forward with an
impeachment inquiry today I'm announcing
the House of Representatives moving
forward with an official impeachment
inquiry I'm directing our six committees
to proceed with their investigations
under that umbrella of impeachment
inquiry the president must be held
accountable no one is above the law
and she continued by explaining that
president Trump's actions here betrayed
his oath of office specifically it is
unclear what are the grounds for
impeachment so there are three possible
grounds for impeachment that have been
presented by Democrats and the media
possible ground number one
Trump is stymieing the whistleblowers
remember there was a member of the
intelligence community who issued a
whistleblower report to the Inspector
General of the intelligence community
the inspector general found that report
urgent enough to report its existence to
Congress at which point the Director of
National Intelligence stepped in and
said hold up a second this is not
fulfilled the statutory requirements we
can't turn over the whistleblower report
Congress then said well no actually you
have to according to the law so that is
an actual conflict over executive
privilege and what exactly is supposed
to be turned over so rationale number
one is the possibility that Congress
says President Trump is engaged in a
cover-up he should be impeached you
won't release the whistleblower report
he should be impeached that's
possibility number one then there is
possibility number
possibility number two is that just the
stuff that Trump has admitted to is
already impeachable meaning that
President Trump has already admitted
that he said to the Ukrainian president
vladimir szalinski that he wanted
ukraine to investigate the joe biden
hunter biden Purisima nexus so going
back to 2016 for those who don't
remember the story joe biden was vice
president his son Hunter was on the
board of a natural gas company in
Ukraine called Purisima and hunter Biden
shouldn't been on that board there's no
reason for him to be on that board other
than the fact that hunter Biden was
related to Joe Biden Joe Biden then
threatened to withhold 1 billion dollars
in American loan guarantees to Ukraine
unless Ukraine got rid of a particular
state prosecutor in Ukraine now to be
fair to Biden that prosecutor was well
believed to be corrupt by the IMF the
International Monetary Fund by the
European Union by the Obama
administration and there are certain
reports that suggest Bloomberg that the
burries m'a investigation being
undertaken by that prosecutor was
already defunct nonetheless Biden has
openly bragged that he got that
prosecutor fired now hidden brag that he
got him fired in order to protect his
son that was sort of the conclusion that
a lot of people took away from the story
although the evidence isn't totally
there to support it so President Trump
wanted Ukraine to investigate that so
the grounds for impeachment number two
the Democrats could be putting forward
is that Trump merely by mentioning Joe
Biden to the Ukrainians by saying to the
Ukrainians would be it would be great if
you investigated that just by doing that
he has stepped into impeachable
territory that is very weak sauce
probably not bad behavior president
should not be going to foreign countries
and asking for their help in
investigating his political opponents
but to be fair Hillary Clinton said the
same thing in 2016 when she worked with
wait for it the Ukrainian ambassador in
order to find information about Donald
Trump's campaign manager Paul Manafort
so that is grounds at number two and it
is a weak rounds and then there is
grounds number three and this is the one
we are all sort of waiting to see if
there's another sheet that drops and
that is the quid pro quo grounds now if
President Trump went to Ukraine and said
listen got a bunch of military aid right
here four hundred million dollars in
military aid and I'm not gonna give it
to you I know that you are under
pressure from the Russians I know that
you are fighting a proxy war with
Russian backed insurgents in Ukraine and
you know what
I'm just not going to give you the
military aid that you need unless you do
it I want and investigate my political
opponent that's impeachable right that
is a quid pro quo that is presumably
bribery it's a violation of criminal
statute it's a serious problem for Trump
so Trump has already admitted that he
talked to the Ukrainians about Biden the
question is whether he connected that
with aid whether he was saying okay your
aid is withheld unless you do what I
want okay so that is the background to
all of this we're gonna get to the rest
of Nancy Pelosi announcement and then
the big breaking news of the day
president Trump has released the
transcript of his call with Vladimir
zalenski and it casts more shadow than
light let's put it that way okay it is
not clear anything up it is not it does
not exonerate the president it also does
not dam the president it is an absolute
Rorschach test and I'm gonna read you
nearly the entire transcript so you can
make it up you make up your mind for
yourself so that you can understand what
is going on and why two possible
interpretations still exist of what
Trump is saying in that phone call we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the importance of the
Second Amendment when the founders
crafted the Constitution the first thing
they did was to make sacred the rights
of the individual to share their ideas
without limitation by their government
that's the first amendment the second
right they enumerated was the right of
the population to protect that speech
and their own persons with force that
would be the Second Amendment I'm a gun
owner because I want to protect my
family you know a lot of people who
threaten us I'm a gun owner because I
want to protect my country against
tyranny because I don't believe that
individual citizens in the United States
who are law-abiding should be unable to
defend themselves against the
encroachments of people who seek to
destroy their rights while owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different starting
a garage buy a Marine veteran more than
two decades ago bravo company
manufacturing BCM for short builds a
professional-grade product built to
combat standards bravo company
manufacturing is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer manufacture
life-saving equipment the people at BCM
assume that when a rifle leaves their
shop it will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas to learn more about bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
bravo company MFG comm you can discover
more about their product special offers
and upcoming news that's Bravo Company
MFG comm if you need more convincing
find out even more
BCM and the fantastic people who run
it's a great company over at youtube.com
slash Bravo Company USA that is
youtube.com slash Bravo company
USA okay so Nancy Pelosi moves on with
her announcement of this impeachment
inquiry by suggesting the president from
has taken actions that betray his oath
of office the president has admitted to
asking the president of Ukraine to take
actions which would benefit him
politically the action of the truck the
actions of the trump presidency revealed
dishonorable fact of the president's
betrayal of his oath of office betrayal
of our national security and betrayal of
the integrity of our elections okay so
obviously the question is whether she
comes up with the grounds does Nancy
Pelosi come up with the guys no it is
worthwhile mentioning just as an aside
the Nancy Pelosi didn't used to be quite
as gung-ho about impeachment when it was
a Democrat in office here's Nancy Pelosi
circa 1998 talking about how impeachment
is a terrible terrible idea
with regard to President Bill Clinton
today the Republican majority is not
judging the present president with
fairness but impeaching him with a
vengeance in the investigation of the
president fundamental principles which
Americans hold dear privacy fairness
checks and balances have been seriously
violated and why because we are here as
we are here today because the
Republicans in the House are paralyzed
with hatred of President Clinton and
until the Republicans free themselves of
this hatred our country will suffer okay
well you could easily flip Clinton for
Trump here and you could say the same
thing about the Democrats they've spent
two-and-a-half years trying to impeach
Trump over Russia allegations that
turned out to be sure nonsense and now
they're trying to go after Trump on this
Ukrainian stuff so if you're a
Republican that is going to be your gut
reaction to this latest crusade by
Democrats amazing how quickly they
swiveled from Russia to Ukraine I mean
like literally within a matter of weeks
okay now the question remains what
exactly did president from to here
because again we gotta get the standards
straight the Democrats are already
shifting the standard they are moving
the standard they've been saying things
like nobody is above the law and
President Trump has already engaged in
bad behavior that he's admitted to by
aoc is already out there suggesting that
Trump has admitted to impeachable
offenses in other words we don't even
need you to an investigation he's
already impeached I think what is going
on in what he has already
okay so the Democrats so the more
radical Democrats are saying we don't
even need an inquiry we don't need an
investigation it's a done deal
we're impeaching but the actual standard
the Democrat said here is going to be
the one that they are held to so if they
believe that it's enough to impeach
Trump just over he requested help on
Biden from the Ukrainians go for it man
really have at it if you think the
American people are gonna go along with
that I really really doubt it I really
know Nancy Pelosi may think that I mean
Nancy Pelosi came out yesterday and she
says the public understands the Trump
Ukraine allegations better than they did
the obstruction of justice allegations
so maybe we have a better case for
impeachment here than we did on the
Miller report this is about the
Constitution of the United States and we
have many other shall we say candidates
for the future more offense in terms of
the constitutional intercept but this
one is the most understandable by the
public and it's really important to know
this it is there is no requirement there
be a quid pro quo in the conversation
okay so she's shifting the standard is
there a quid pro quo is there not a quid
pro quo unclear what she wants so she
can try to impeach on the basis of no
quid pro quo right she can but I think
that that is going to fail dramatically
if she believes the American people are
going to throw Trump out of office in
ignominy in ignominy based on he asked
zolensky in Ukraine to look into Joe and
hunter Biden and burries m'a I don't
think so I don't think so it's only if
people feel like Trump was using
American taxpayer dollars from Democrats
and Republicans from people all across
the political spectrum in order to
target his political opponent right that
he was actually withholding
on the basis of this that it turns into
a real impeachable offense that is the
line that I think is gonna end up being
drawn now that brings us to the release
of the transcript today because the
Democrats and the Republicans in the
Senate actually are pushing very hard
for the Trump administration to release
materials and Trump's responsive in okay
okay sure I'm gonna release it so today
he'll release the full transcript of his
call from July 25th 2019 at 9:33 a.m.
from 903 to 9:33 a.m. you'll release the
full transcript of that call to the
public with Vladimir zalenski the
president of Ukraine we're gonna go
through it line by line in just one
second first let's talk about your sleep
quality so I got to tell you when I'm on
the road I just do not sleep well and
one of the reasons I don't sleep well
not just as I'm not in my own bed but
really cuz I'm not in my own bed right
I'm not in my own mattress I'm not on my
own mattress hulex sleep has created not
just a mattress that is in my house but
a mattress that is personalized it to me
they have a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you no matter how
you sleep on the side on your back hot
sleeper whatever helix can make what
your body needs just go to helix sleep
calm slash Ben take their two minute
sleep quiz and they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life when I'm on
the road I can't wait to get home and
onto that personalized mattress that is
made just for me it is incredibly
comfortable because it was uniquely
tailored just for me for couples helix
can even split the mattress down the
middle providing individual support
needs and fuel preferences for each side
they've got a 10 year warranty and you
get to try it out for a hundred nights
at risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 125 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
get up to 125 bucks off at helix sleep
comm slash Ben that's helix sleep comm
slash Ben for up to 125 dollars off your
mattress order helix sleep comm slash
Ben okay so now the President of the
United States has responded to these
calls for transparency by actually
suggesting he's going to provide the
transparency that is desired so this
takes off the table the second of the
the first of the democratic rationales
for impeachment so first rationale was
he's covering it up second rationale was
he has some Lensky for Hubbell Biden
third rationales quid pro quo as I say I
don't think the second rationale the PS
olenski for help with Biden is enough
for the
Kratts to impeach Trump or for any
Republicans in the Senate to go along
with it the whistleblower cover-up might
have been a grounds right to cover up
his worse than the crime as the saying
usually does but Trump isn't covering it
up so as it turns out the White House is
now going to work with Congress not only
to release the transcript of this
conversation between zalenski of Ukraine
and the President of the United States
but also they're gonna work to release
the whistleblower complaint and we'll
get to that in a moment but today the
big news was that they dropped the full
transcript and a couple of preliminary
words about the full transcript how you
interpret this transcript is almost
entirely dependent on what you think of
Trump as a human being and this is true
of nearly every conversation that you
that you think about any conversation
you think about if you were to read a
transcript of that conversation and
you'd remove the name of the person
saying things that would make a very big
difference in how you interpret the
conversation right whether I'm singing
my wife or my business partner that
makes a big difference they can say the
exact same thing and it means two
completely separate things so your
impression of Trump and what he is as a
person you see a scattered thinker is he
somebody who sort of just blurts out
what is on his mind is he somebody who
says ill-advised things and then walks
them back or is he somebody who plans is
he a bully who plans right is he's
somebody who sits there and applies
leverage turns the screw on people and
that's really what he desires to do or
is he just a guy who has sort of these
fragment or thoughts maybe he's a bully
maybe his bull in a china shop but he
sort of has fragmentary thoughts and he
spits things out there and he doesn't
mean them seriously and then he walks
them back now the answer may be that he
is both of those things and it sort of
depends on the time of day but that
doesn't clear it up
so as we will see from the transcript
your interpretation of who Donald Trump
is really heavily affect how you're
about to hear the transcript that we are
about to read okay so here is the
transcript we're gonna go through it so
you have all the information because
again on this show we try to provide you
all the information and then I'll
provide analysis but you can make up
your own mind because on major issues of
the day you should you're an adult so
here is the here's the transcript the
president opens the call by
congratulating Solinsky on his big win
he says congratulations on a great
victory we all watched from the United
States and he did a terrific job the way
you came from behind somebody who wasn't
give
much of a chance and you ended up
winning easily it's a fantastic
achievement congratulations Solinsky
then says you're absolutely right mr.
president we did win Bing and we worked
hard for this we worked a lot but I
would like to confess to you that I had
an opportunity to learn from you
we used quite a few of your skills and
knowledge and were able to use it as an
example for our elections and yes it is
true that these were unique elections we
were in a unique situation that we were
able to achieve the unique success I'm
able to tell you the following the first
time you called me to congratulate me
when I won my presidential election and
the second time you are now calling me
when my party won the parliamentary
election I think I should run more often
so you can call me more often and we can
talk over the phone more often okay so
first thing to note it is obvious that
someone skis trying to butter Trump up I
mean that is it that is obvious because
and why wouldn't he right if you are a
foreign leader and you've watched
President Trump to foreign relations for
the last couple of years what you know
more than anything else is if you
develop a warm a personal relationship
with Trump he is more likely to give you
what you want so this does add a wrinkle
okay so people have been saying that
Trump is requesting a quid pro quo what
if it was zalenski who is actually sort
of requesting the quid pro quo in other
words what if what if Trump was holding
up the Ukrainian aid for what he thought
were good reasons and zalenski was
trying to get Trump to release the aid
by buttering Trump up right well what if
that was the actual case because the
transcript kind of reads like that I
mean from the very beginning you've got
Solinsky talking about how he learned
from Trump in his election cycle and all
this kind of stuff like it is obvious
that his advisers told him you know what
you should do you should really massage
Trump you should massage him right look
how kim jeong-hoon massages him
look how pbteen yahoo massages him look
how the look how the Eastern European
leaders in the area massaged him and the
or bonds of the world massage him if you
massage him things will go better for
you
and so Lenski is taking the attack right
from the outside right from the outside
he is saying to Trump you know I want to
be just like you mr. Trump and so there
is that aspect of the conversation and
the other side of the conversation does
matter because as we will see some of
the topics that are brought up in the
conversation that have to do with things
Ukraine can do for the United States are
actually brought up by zalenski not by
Trump okay so he he brothers him up and
then Trump says that's a very good idea
I think your country is very happy about
that and szalinski said well yes to tell
you the truth we are trying to work hard
because we want to drain the swamp here
in our country we brought in many many
new people
not the old politicians not the typical
politicians because you want to have a
new format and a new type of government
you are a great teacher for us and in
that right again it's more buttering up
of Trump on a personal level and he is
the one who first mentions the drain the
swamp kind of stuff now he's using
Trump's phraseology because he is trying
to butter Trump up obviously 100 percent
obvious right it is also true that he
brings up the corruption stuff well that
opens the door to Trump talking about
corruption and in a second we are going
to get to the president talking about
Ukrainian aid right this is sort of the
key aspect and how you read this
paragraph particularly is going to
inform whether you see this conversation
as if not proof of a quid pro quo then
some sort of indicator that a quid pro
quo was in the making and that you need
more research on it I'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that you don't really want to
go to the post office post office does a
lot of great things it may even be a fun
place to be sometimes but the fact is
you don't want to take all your packages
put them in the car schlep them over to
the post office get a parking ticket
slep know inside wait in line and post
office is great but you don't have time
for that instead you should be using
stamps calm
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US postal office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
you simply use your computer and you can
print official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once that
mail is ready you just handed your mail
carrier or you drop it in a mailbox it
is indeed that simple stamps.com is a
no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses already use stamps calm you
know getting stamps performant had to go
to the grocery store or down to the post
office no more was an IU stamps icon
because it saves me time and it saves me
money and right now my listeners get a
special offer
it includes a four week trial plus free
postage Anne's digital scale no long
term commitment just go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in Shapiro that stamps
comm enter Shapiro once more stamps comm
and use that code Shapiro to get your
four week trial plus free postage and
digital skill no long term commitment
great great deals go check them out
great company stamps.com
okay so now we get to the crux of the
matter or as my father says the meat of
the matter Uncle Eddie okay so the
President of the United States finally
gets to ukrainian aid and here's what he
says
I'm going through the transcription
that's very nice of you to say that I
will say we do a lot for Ukraine we
spend a lot of effort and a lot of time
much more than the European countries
are doing and they should be helping you
more than they are Germany does almost
nothing for you all they do is talk and
I think it's something that you should
really ask them about when I was
speaking to angle a Merkel she talks
Ukraine but she doesn't do anything a
lot of the European countries are the
same way so I think it's something you
want to look at but the United States
has been very very good to Ukraine I
wouldn't say that it's reciprocal
necessarily because things are happening
that are not good but the United States
has been very very good to Ukraine okay
so a couple of things here one Trump has
been saying the reason he withheld the
aid from Ukraine is because he wanted
the Europeans to pay up he's making that
pretty explicit in this paragraph so he
wasn't lying about that right that has
been a Bugaboo of from very very long
time is that the Europeans don't pay
their fair share when it comes to
international arrangements including
foreign aid right they don't pay their
fair share in NATO is one of trumps main
complaints he believes they don't pay
their fair share at the UN has been
Trump's complaint and he believes they
don't pay their fair share when it comes
to Ukrainian aid he's saying the
Europeans should do more okay so that
part Trump is telling the truth about
right the Democrats keep saying that
Trump has shifted his rationale on why
he is holding back
Ukrainian aid or why he held back
Ukrainian aid they say the real reason
is because he wanted to leverage the
Ukrainians to research Joe Biden but
Trump has said well there are a couple
reasons one is because the Europeans
should pay more okay he says that
explicitly in the call and the other is
because of generalized concerns about
corruption and that brings us to that
last line right there he says I wouldn't
say that it's reciprocal necessarily
because things are happening that are
not good but the United States has been
very very good to Ukraine now when he
talks about reciprocal is does he mean I
need you to give me something then I'll
give you something right which looks
more like a quid pro quo or it does
what'd he mean or does he mean simply we
give you a lot of aid and you're not
doing a great job over there
hey there corruption issues over there
because if that's the question and
that's exactly what Joe Biden said to
Ukraine back in 2016 right Joe Biden
said you don't get a billion dollars in
loan guarantees unless you clean up your
act so it sounds like Trump could be
saying that too so again as I say
Rorschach test if you think going in
that there's a quid pro quo conversation
it sounds like a quid pro quo
conversation if you think that it's not
it kind of doesn't
okay so zolensky continues to read this
I think the fairest way to say this is
that zalenski is
reading this as a conversation in which
he can try to pry aid out of President
Trump by buttering him up now does that
mean that Trump himself perceived the
conversation that way or that Trump
actually was withholding aid in order to
be buttered up I mean what what does
that mean right exactly just because
zolensky wanted the aide to come forth
as we'll see and because he was offering
stuff to Trump that does not necessarily
mean that Trump was soliciting the stuff
in exchange for the aide right it's it's
it's a bit murky it's a bit murky and as
I say there are a couple of different
plausible reads which is why this
controversy is not gonna end today I
think the transcript is not gonna end
the controversy in fact it's gonna fan
the flames of the controversy okay so
zalenski then responds yes yes you are
absolutely right not only 100% but
actually 1,000% and I can tell you the
following I did talk to Angela Merkel
and I did meet with her I also met and
talked with McCrone the leader of France
and I told them they are not doing quite
as much as they need to be doing on the
sanctions with the sanctions they're not
enforcing the sanctions they are not
working as much as they should work for
Ukraine it turns out that even though
logically the European Union should be
our biggest partner but technically the
United States is a much bigger partner
than the European Union and I'm very
grateful to you for that because the
u.s. is doing quite a lot for Ukraine
much more than the EU especially when we
are talking about sanctions against the
Russian Federation I would also like to
thank you for your great support in the
area of defense we are ready to continue
to cooperate for the next step
specifically we are almost ready to buy
more javelins from the United States for
defense purposes ok so now he is
explicitly bringing up the military
defense issue right at this point like a
week beforehand Trump had instructed the
Office of Management and Budget director
Mick Mulvaney to hold up the Ukrainian
aid 400 million dollars in Ukrainian aid
that was directed toward defense so now
zelinsky's bringing it up just openly
right he's explicitly asking for more
javelin missiles to defend against the
the Russian aggression that is occurring
in Ukraine so now it's on the table and
from here the conversation goes into a a
bunch of things that Trump would like to
see Ukraine gets on and we'll get to
those things momentarily but the
question is Solinsky seems to perceive
this as what can I do to get you to give
the military aid and Trump's tip Trump
seems to perceive this as we can talk
about military aid in a general
and we should talk about military aid
and there may be certain preconditions
that the country wants to set on the
military aid namely anti-corruption and
then he mentions Biden and the question
is is he conditioning the aid on the
Biden stuff or is he conditioning the
aid on generalized concerns about
corruption which is what he has said
before right that is the that is the
actual question here so Solinsky finally
brings up the actual military aid and
here is how President Trump responds he
says I would like you to do us a favor
though because our country has been
through a lot and Ukraine knows a lot
about it so the question now again the
whole thing's were Rorschach test when
Trump says I would like you to do us a
favor our people now gonna read that as
you just said military aid now do me a
favor go after my enemies or is it
zolensky says here I want you to give
military aid when Trump says well
there's a bunch of stuff you have to do
among those things I want you to fight
corruption and one of the aspects of
corruption is X it's a again I keep
emphasizing because I want to be as
intellectually honest as possible and I
want everybody else to be as
intellectually honest as possible that
there are several different plausible
reads of this particular conversation
and it seems like Solinsky is in fact
trying to butter Trump up so Trump opens
his favor requests not by talking about
Biden now if you if it were a full-on
open quid pro quo you would expect at
this point that zalenski says we're
ready to buy more javelins from the
united states for defense purposes and
Trump says first I need you to prosecute
Biden right that's what you would expect
that's not really where the conversation
goes so where the conversation goes next
is Trump says I would like you to do us
a favor though because our country has
been through a lot and Ukraine knows a
lot about it I would like you to find
out what happened with the whole
situation with Ukraine they say
CrowdStrike I guess you have one of your
wealthy people the server they say
Ukraine has it okay so this is a
reference to the firm that hacked
Hillary Clinton's emails and the DNC so
he's opening not with the Biden stuff
but with a generalized point which is
basically correct that Ukraine should
investigate Ukrainian interference in
the 2016 election which is totally
appropriate there's nothing wrong with
Trump saying that right so far nothing
in the conversation has been incredibly
wrong he says there are a lot of things
that went on the whole situation I think
your sir
yourself with some of the same people
I'd like to have the Attorney General
call you or your people I would like you
to get to the bottom of it as you saw
yesterday that whole nonsense ended with
a very poor performance by a man named
Robert Muller an incompetent performance
but they say a lot of it started with
Ukraine whatever you can do it's very
important that you do it if that's
possible okay and then szalinski
responds yes it is very important for me
and everything that you just mentioned
earlier for me as president it is very
important and we are open for any future
cooperation we are ready to open a new
page on cooperation in relations between
the United States and Ukraine for that
purpose I just recalled our ambassador
from the United States and he will be
replaced by a very competent and very
experienced ambassador who will work
hard on making sure that our two nations
are getting closer now the Ukrainian
ambassador issue is presumably a
reference to the article in Politico
from 2017 in which the embassy the
Ukrainian embassy in Washington DC was
working with sources from the DNC
to research pommes Anna fort and release
that information and the Ambassador
allegedly was involved in that so the
Ukrainian president is saying well we're
gonna recall that ambassador that
ambassador is out and then it's the
Ukrainian ambassador who raises Rudy
Giuliani that's not Trump Ukrainian basa
der seems to be trying to wheedle Trump
right the whole thing is him trying to
massage Trump that's the entire
conversation so he continues by then
talking about Rudy Giuliani who is the
president's personal lawyer he says I
will personally tell you one of my
assistants spoke with mr. Giuliani just
recently we're hoping very much that mr.
Giuliani will be able to travel to
Ukraine and we will meet once he comes
to Ukraine I just wanted to assure you
once again you have nobody but friends
around us I will make sure that I
surround myself with the best and most
experienced people I also wanted to tell
you that we are friends we are great
friends and you mr. president have
friends in our country so we can
continue our strategic partnership I
also plan to surround myself with great
people and in addition to that
investigation I guarantee as president
of Ukraine that all the investigations
will be done openly and candidly that I
can assure you so again this is Olinsky
trying to butter up Trump maybe this all
falls under the broad rubric of
corruption of the anti-corruption right
of Trump saying the same thing that
Biden said in 2016
and that the Obama administration said
in 2016 8 is contingent on
anti-corruption efforts and maybe this
all falls under that rubric but once he
brings up Giuliani
this is where things start to take the
sideways turn that has created all
headlines so president Trump immediately
picks up on the reference to Giuliani
and he starts talking about Giuliani and
Biden right he says good because I heard
you had a prosecutor who is very good
and he was shut down and that's really
unfair a lot of people are talking about
that the way they shut your shut your
very good prosecutor down and you had
some very bad people involved mr.
Giuliani is a highly respected man he
was the mayor of New York City a great
mayor and I would like him to call you I
will ask him to call you along with the
Attorney General
Rudy very much knows what's happening
and he has a very capable guy if he
could speak to him that would be great
now again this is where he starts at
cross streams that are that are
inappropriate not necessarily
impeachable because again is he
conditioning aid on Rudy Giuliani being
given information about Biden not clear
from the conversation not clear is it
inappropriate for him to bring his
personal attorney and campaign attorney
into a conversation with the Attorney
General about Joe Biden yeah that's
pretty inappropriate so he says Rudy
very much knows what's happening and
he's a very capable guy if he could
speak to him that would be great the
former ambassador from the United States
the woman was bad news and the people
she was dealing with in the Ukraine were
bad news so I just want you to know that
the other thing and here's where Trump
decides to just go full-bore on the
Biden stuff he says the other thing
there's a lot of talk about Biden's son
that Biden stopped the prosecution and a
lot of people want to find out about
that so whatever you can do what the
Attorney General would be great
Biden went around bragging that he
stopped the prosecution so if you can
look into it and sounds horrible to me
hey now
couple possible reads one is the obvious
rate he doesn't like Biden he wants
Biden out you know once Ukraine to go
after him is that explicitly connected
to the ablest it is happening in a
conversation that has mentioned foreign
aid including military aid but is it
conditioned is it explicitly conditioned
if so Lenski does not investigate Biden
is the military aid gonna continue to be
withheld that's not clear from the
conversation because again there's a lot
in the conversation another read is
these sort of read that the Obama
administration was using in early 2016
which is that if Ukraine was not going
to investigate man afford then were they
truly anti corruption right some is
trumps assuming the Biden stuff under
the broader anti-corruption rubric
that's a I would says a pretty
flattering read for president Trump it
doesn't sound particular
accurate to me but Trump brings up Biden
and then Solinsky says I wanted to tell
you about the prosecutor first of all I
understand that I'm I understand and uh
knowledgable about the situation since
we have won the absolute majority in our
Parliament the next prosecutor general
will be 100% my person my candidate will
be approved by the Parliament and will
start as a new prosecutor in September
he or she will look into the situation
specifically to the company that you
mentioned in this issue
the issue of the investigation of the
case is actually the issue of making
sure to restore the honesty so you'll
take care of that and we'll work on the
investigation of the case right so
zolensky is now putting this in the
broader rubric not of the campaign but
of anti-corruption efforts that he's
trying to prove to Trump he says on top
of that I would kindly ask you if you
have any additional information that you
can provide to us it would be very
helpful for the investigation to make
sure that we administer justice in our
country with regard to the ambassador to
the United States from Ukraine as far as
I recall her name was Ivanovich it was
great that you were the first one who
told me she was a band ambassador
because I agree with you 100% her
attitude toward me was far from the best
as she admired the previous president
and she was on his side she would not
accept me as new president well enough
and Trump responded well she's gonna go
through some things I will have mr.
Giuliani give you a call I'm also going
to have a tourney general bar call and
we'll get to the bottom of it I'm sure
you will figure it out I heard the
prosecutor was treated very badly and he
was a very fair prosecutor so good luck
with everything
your economy is gonna get better and
better I predict you have a lot of
assets it's a great country at many
Ukrainian friends they are incredible
people okay and then zalenski responds
with continuing to butter up Trump I'd
say you can tell that we're gonna talk
about the general dynamics in just a
second of the call what it means going
forward and really why this is sort of
the opening of the investigation not the
end of the investigation
so when ski says I would like to tell
you I also have quite a few Ukrainian
friends that live in the United States
actually the last time I traveled to the
US I stayed in New York near Central
Park and I stayed at the Trump Tower
right this is him again trying to just
massage Trump he said I will talk to
them
and I hope to see them again in the
future I also wanted to thank you for
your invitation to visit the u.s.
specifically Washington DC on the other
hand I also want to ensure you that will
be very serious about the case and we
work on the investigation so he is
picking up on Trump's focus on the Biden
stuff and saying I would love to do that
so it is possible again that there's a
bit of a disconnect here or as possible
there's no disconnect so if there's a
disconnect that is connected Trump
talking about aid and then being like
also you know just as a general rule
there's a bunch of stuff I want you to
do and then Solinsky taking that as oh
if you want the if I want the aid I have
to do XY and Z now what you really need
is more than the phone call what you
really need is somebody if you wanted to
impeach Trump if you're the Democrats
what you need is a smoking gun
conversation what from said to somebody
guys know a to Ukraine until they
investigate Biden right you do need that
smoking gun you need that final data
point linked in order to get to the quid
pro quo the conversation is not an
explicit quid pro quo if you're reading
it with eight with a jaundiced eye about
President Trump if you think he's really
corrupt if you think a quid pro quo is
there then you read the conversation and
it sort of supports the story if you
think there's no quid pro quo then it
sounds like Trump basically talking
about Aid and then talking about stuff
he'd like to see Ukraine to but not
conditioning one on the other and she's
a friendly conversation about things
we'd like to see you do and also about a
because these are issues that both are
going to come up in a conversation so
when ski seems to aim for if you read
zolensky side of the conversation it
sounds like he's trying to wheedle Trump
into getting a right that does sound
like what it is from zelinsky's point of
view and Solinsky says I believe it can
be very successful in cooperating on
energy independence with the u.s. we're
already working on cooperation we're
buying American oil but I'm very hopeful
for a future meeting again everything he
says is attempting to to pry something
out of Trump he says we'll have more
time and more opportunities to discuss
these opportunities and get to know each
other better I'd like to thank you very
much for your support and then Trump
goes back to Rudy and bar he says I
appreciate that I will tell Rudy an
attorney general bar to call thank you
whenever you'd like to come to the White
House feel free to give us a call give
us a date and then zalenski talks about
inviting Trump to Kiev and visiting
Ukraine and then Trump says okay we can
work that out and then they say goodbye
so that is the content of the
conversation we're gonna get to analysis
of that conversation in just one second
first let's talk without making your
company better you know hiring can be a
slow arduous process calf fails for a
CEO Oh Dylan Moskowitz needed to hire a
director of coffee for his organic
coffee company but he was having trouble
finding qualified applicants so he
switched over to zip recruiter zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you it's
technology identifies people with the
right experience and then invites them
to apply to your job so you will get
qualified candidates
Dylan posted his job on zip Roker said
he was impressed by how quickly he had
great candidates apply he also used zip
can zip recruiters candidate rating
feature to filter applicants so you
could focus on just the most relevant
applicants and that is how Dylan found
his new director of coffee in just a few
days with results like that it is no
wonder that four out of five employers
who post on zip recruiter data quality
candidate within the very first day you
know every single day I sit around here
and I think how could I make my company
better and every single day I think of a
producer to rip on about you know
replacing them and making the company
better by getting rid of one of these
producers normally we even take a poll
before these ads decide which producer
should come up in the ads so today
Andrew Clavin congratulation it's you
you're not actually a producer but if I
wanted to get rid of Drew and get a host
who wasn't you know on the verge of
death then the first place I would be
looking is super career.com see why zip
recruiter is effective for businesses of
all sizes try zip recruiter for free at
our web address zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire that is zip recruiter com
slash at Dai ly wre zip recruiter comm
slash at Daily wires if recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire ok so
we're gonna get to much much more on
impeachment or g9g and the effects of
this conversation and what comes next
first you have to go over to daily wired
and subscribe for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe to daily wire for 99 bucks a
year you also get this the very greatest
in beverage vessels the leftist year's
hunt or cold tumbler refilling daily
delicious you get all sorts of great
wonderful things behind the paywall you
get our Sunday special early on Saturday
there's a bunch of great Sunday specials
coming up you get to be part of the
mailbag you get to join us during
backstages
you get to join us during the conference
like all sorts of great stuff em we just
relaunched the website we picked a hell
of a morning to do it but we just
relaunched the website which makes
subscriptions a lot easier and a lot
better so go check us out right now at
daily wire comm and subscribe we really
appreciate it we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
already so the bottom line about this
conversation he had to sum it up in one
line is that this is the beating of the
inquiry not the end because it is a
Rorschach test because it is plausible
to read the conversation as a sort of
soft quid pro quo a if you don't hand
over the if if if you don't give me what
I want you don't get the aid
conversation and it is also plausible to
read it as let's talk about the aid you
got to make some anti-corruption efforts
one of the things I'd like to see you do
is investigate Joe Biden but it's not
conditional right it is possible to read
it in a variety of ways that means that
the investigation is going to continue
and it means that everybody who has had
discussions with Trump about Ukraine and
Ukrainian aid is going to be called as a
witness because the fact is that Trump
did not give good excuses to Congress
about why exactly he had not given aid
to Ukraine by Mitch McConnell was asked
about this yesterday Mitch McConnell
explicitly said I don't know I said I
have no idea why the president didn't
just give the aid to Ukraine right it is
it is not clear why he didn't give the
aid to Ukraine meanwhile there's a
report from the Washington Post today
reporters on that story Greg Miller Josh
Dow C Paulson on Ellen Nakashima so the
Washington Post got him all out on this
story of course saying Giuliani ran
shadowy Ukraine policy sidelining and
alarming officials according to the post
president Trump's attempt to pressure
the leader of Ukraine followed a
month-long fight inside the
administration that sidelined national
security officials and empowered
political loyalists including the
president's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani to exploit through the u.s.
relationship with Kiev current and
former US officials said the sequence
which began early this year involved the
abrupt removal of the US ambassador to
Ukraine
the circumvention of senior officials on
the National Security Council
and the suspension of hundreds of
millions of dollars of aid administered
by the defense in state departments all
s key officials from these agencies
struggle to piece together Giuliani's
activities from news reports several
officials described tense meetings on
Ukraine among national security
officials at the White House leading up
to the president's phone call on July
25th sessions that led some participants
to fear that Trump and those close to
him appeared prepared to use u.s.
leverage with the new leader of Ukraine
for Trump's political game and now this
is the Washington Post
trying to suss out a smoking gun where
the evidence does not back The Smoking
Gun yet so yes we know that Rudy
in Ukraine we've known that for what two
years now that Rudy Guiliani was walking
around Ukraine looking for dirt on
hunter Biden and burries MA and all the
rest of this does that mean that it
totally overtook Ukrainian policy not
clear and if you are a a disgruntled
former employee if you're somebody who
is working in Ukraine and Trump fired
you for any reason you might have an
interest in suggesting that Trump had
gone out of his way to get rid of you so
that he could do his political
manipulation and we've seen this story
before right James Comey suggested the
same thing when Trump fired him from the
FBI Comey then claimed that Trump did so
for corrupt reasons as opposed to just
because Trump was frustrated with him
and one of the problems with a governing
strategy of chaos which is what Trump
does is it leaves an awful lot up for
speculation and it leaves an awful lot
of pissed-off disgruntled people on the
other end and this story would be no
different according to the Washington
Post as those worries intensified some
senior officials work behind the scenes
to hold off a trump meeting or call with
ukrainian President Vladimir zalenski
out of concern that Trump would use the
conversation to press Kiev for damaging
information on Trump's potential rival
in the 2020 race Joe Biden and Biden son
Hunter one former official said an awful
lot of people were trying to keep a
meeting from happening for the reason
that it would not be focused on Ukraine
US relations the White House disputed
the account saying no such concerns were
raised in the Security Council meetings
and that trumps focus was on urging
Ukraine to root out corruption so again
lack of clarity lack of clarity so where
does this go from here so the Democrats
and the Republicans have now issued a
unanimous call from the Senate for the
actual whistleblower report to be turned
over the whistleblower Report presumably
includes beyond something beyond the
transcript of the phone call presumably
it would include information about other
conversations that were had about
Ukraine or other lower-level
conversations that were had between
Ukraine and the Trump administration and
so Congress wants to see that
information now this raises some pretty
significant national security issues for
the future namely the president is
supposed to be able to conduct foreign
policy making every conversation that he
has subject to congressional review does
destroy a lot of the constitutional
order the commander-in-chief does have
plenary power over the USS foreign
policy he's the sole policy maker when
it comes to having conversations with
foreign leaders for
example in shaping American policy along
those lines negotiating treaties talking
about foreign aid and all the rest of it
so this sort of new world where Trump is
releasing transcripts it's not great it
may be necessary for Trump to do so at
this point because of how this all went
down but it isn't great for the office
of the presidency John you the former
lawyer for the for the Bush
administration now law professor at
University of California Berkeley he has
a piece in The New York Times talking
about this today say he says we should
beware that rushing into an impeachment
made you long term harm to the
presidency and our national security the
Constitution vests the president with
the authority to conduct foreign policy
and the responsibility to protect the
nation's security a president even one
who is possibly engaging in wrongdoing
must have confidence in the
confidentiality of his communications or
he will be unable to perform his
constitutional duties and our
international relations will fall victim
to governance by committee so turning
over transcripts of private phone calls
with foreign leaders to Congress and
making them public is not good policy
you points out that George Washington in
1796 refused to provide the house with
the Jay Treaty negotiating record
presidents have claimed the right not
just to communicate with foreign leaders
but also to keep national security
information secret and now we are
violating all of that so on a
going-forward basis this is pretty
dangerous stuff but it's pretty obvious
at this point that Trump does not have
much of a political choice again the
Senate yesterday passed a unanimous
resolution to hand the whistleblower
complaints to the intelligence
committees presumably whatever is
classified will be kept behind closed
doors
McConnell bypassed normal Senate
procedures to move Chuck Schumer's
request on this to a vote without any
floor debate so this led a lot of people
on the right to speculate okay there's
nothing in the whistleblower report and
that is backed by a report in The
Washington Times yesterday and a Fox
News report on Tuesday evening citing a
senior Trump administration official who
said that the intelligence community
Inspector General who judged the
complaint the whistleblower complaint
found that the person who wrote it had
political bias in favor of a rival
candidate for president the rival
candidate was not identified according
to Fox News but the substance of Trump's
conversation involved Joe Biden so will
the whistleblower report actually cut
against
the accusations against Trump will make
it look like a partisan hit job a
witch-hunt as president Trump has
suggested the Trump has already tweeted
out about all of this right Trump
tweeted out last night in the aftermath
of the move by Pelosi to open an
official impeachment inquiry he said
such an important day at the United
Nations so much work so much success and
the Democrats purposely had to ruin and
demean it with more breaking news
witch-hunt garbage so bad for our
country and that obviously is gonna be
how Trump treats this cuz again I mean
he treated all of this the same way with
Trump brush I and ended up being right
on that so it is unclear where this is
all going Hillary Clinton for her part
is super excited about this
maybe she's unaware that if Trump is
impeached she does not become president
Mike Pence does but she endorsed an
impeachment inquiry she told People
magazine which is still interviewing
Hillary Clinton she said I'm not in
favor of moving toward impeachment I did
not come to that decision easily or
quickly then I'm in favor of moving
toward impeachment rather but this is an
emergency as I see it this latest
behavior around Ukraine trying to enlist
the president of Ukraine in a plot to
undermine former VP Biden or lose the
military aid he needs to defend against
Trump's friend Vladimir Putin if that's
not an impeachable offense I don't know
what is now again Hillary Clinton and
her campaign worked with the Ukrainian
government with the Ukrainian ambassador
to Washington DC to dig up dirt on
Donald Trump's campaign manager in 2016
so if her complaint is working with
foreign governments to dig up dirt she
has no complaints really if the
complaint is quid pro quo that is a bit
of a different story and then the
question is is the quid pro quo designed
to benefit Trump's campaign or is it
really just Trump making a general
anti-corruption point and he thinks that
the currently Biden thing is a corrupt
thing and so he is mentioning that as
one point among many now the Senate GOP
is moving to quash articles of
impeachment
Senator John Kennedy said my response to
Democrats is go hard or go home he said
if you want to impeach him stop talking
do it go to Amazon buy a spine do it and
let's get after it he said I think the
public will feel like it is more
harassment and president from himself
suggested that it will be a positive for
him he said impeachment will probably
pay off to his benefit clip 9 the best
it's ever done and I just heard
that you'd like to impeach and they're
gonna lose the election and they figured
this is a thing to do this never
happened where we were in the election
and I mean if she does that they all say
that's a positive for me from the
election
you could also say who needs it's bad
for the country then they wonder why
they don't get gun legislation done then
they wonder why they don't get drug
prices lower and as I say Trump has
flipped the tables on the Democrats by
basically pursuing radical transparency
he could have he could have easily
argued executive privilege over the
transcript of the phone call he did not
i Chuck Grassley senator from Iowa who's
a senior member of the Judiciary
Committee said correctly he can't tell
me they're talking about impeachment
when the president is cooperating with
them 100% to release these things he
said it's premature to talk about
impeachment Senator Rand Paul of
Kentucky said I think the Democrats have
made this such a partisan exercise that
I think most of the public has
discounted the idea of it I think most
people believe it's become sort of a
political attack on the president and
nothing more Paul did hedge his bets a
bet he said it's hard to predict exactly
how events are going to unfold now
President Trump's campaign is ramping up
fundraising and he sees this presumably
as a big winner with his base because
now it looks like they're coming after
him and coming after him hard which
presumably they are the asks began as
House Speaker Pelosi prepared her
announcements there were emails texts
tweets a video directing Trump
supporters to a new Republican portal
designed to capitalize on Trump's army
of online donors according to the
Washington Post there's an email to
supporters Tuesday afternoon and said
the Democrats thrive on silencing and
intimidating his supporters like you
friend they want to take your vote away
President Trump wants to know who stood
with him when it mattered most so watch
for Trump to pick up serious money in
the aftermath of the Democrats pushing
for impeachment meanwhile even Tulsi
Gabbard in the Democratic Party who just
made the next democratic debate actually
which should be fascinating because she
is just she's a machine when it comes to
destroying other Democratic politicians
see Kamala Harris Tulsi Gabbard came out
yesterday she said I'm not so sure about
the so impeachment thing guys my
position remains the same I think that
impeachment would be terribly divisive
four are already very divided country
even on an impeachment inquiry I feel
and I think Congo
needs to exercise oversight over you
know the information that's been leaked
I think that it's important that this
transcript is released to Congress so
the Congress can do its job but I think
impeach the question of impeachment
really would further tear apart and
already divided country I think it's
important that Donald Trump is defeated
I believe I can defeat him in 2020 but
as the voters who need to make that
choice unequivocally I mean the bottom
line here is that that's probably
correct Nancy Pelosi did not have much
choice she's being buoyed by her own
caucus and with the with the new reports
a momentum hit fever pitch and she just
could not hold back the dam anymore she
could not hold back the she was she was
standing there trying to hold back that
Dam and the Democrats have just overcome
her so likeliest scenario here Trump
gets impeached in the house because the
Democrats have a majority it goes to the
Senate but are they going to uncover any
real information about a quid pro quo
here the Democrats are gonna suggest
that the transcript itself is
dispositive it is not they need more
information they need to connect all the
dots all the dots have to be connected
if you want to impeach somebody
otherwise you know you have an
opportunity to get rid of him in 14
months if you don't like him if the
Democrats shoot here and they miss it's
gonna be really really bad for them if
Donald Trump survives an impeachment
attempt and it looks like Democrats
basically went out there on a limb and
are mad because Trump mentioned Joe
Biden to the president of Ukraine I
think most voters are jaded enough that
they are not going to see that as
Democrats standing on principle and
impeaching Trump for violation of
constitutional duty they're going to see
it as Democrats being partisan hacks who
are attempting to destroy the President
of the United States okay time for a
quick thing that I hate there are no
things I like today because there's
really not much to like it is time for a
quick thing that I hate okay so you want
to hear the most garbage story of the
day maybe of the week maybe of the year
I mean this is just a massively garbage
story so there was this guy named Carson
King Carson King is a like a security
guard who works in Iowa and he's a fan
of Iowa State so he went to a game and
at this game he held up a sign and on
September 13th the sign read Bush Lite
supply needs replenishing venmo Carson
came 25 he did that he held up the sign
at ESPN College GameDay at Jack trice
Stadium in Ames and then the same car
national attention and people around the
country started just randomly giving him
money within just with it within a day
within two days people had given him
over 1 million dollars for beer I mean
just like a funny social media thing
people just gave him over 1 million
dollars for beer and then he did
something pretty incredible right he's
raised over a million dollars I mean
that's enough to retire on in Iowa right
and Carson King took that money he's 24
years old he took that money and he gave
it to the University of Iowa stead
family Children's Hospital for cancer
research he took that entire million
dollars and he handed it over for a
cancer research that's an amazing story
right it was an amazing story but
because we live in the worst timeline
social media then decided to destroy
this guy
and so what did they do people went back
into his Twitter account they found
something that he tweeted that was
racist eight years ago when he was 16
years old he made some sort of reference
quoting and referencing the show Tosh
Tosh point O which was the show on
Comedy Central is a racially charged
message Hey and he had a contract with
anheuser-busch which had announced that
it would match his donation to the
University of Iowa's Ted family
Children's Hospital and they ripped away
whatever they were doing with him they
said they would no longer associate with
him he held a press conference on
Tuesday to discuss the post he said
eight years ago when I was a sophomore
in high school I made some social media
post with my friends that quoted in
reference to show tosh point-o one of
those posters brought to my attention by
a member of the media today he said the
Des Moines Register who uncovered this
has been nothing but kinds and all their
coverage
I appreciate the reporter pointing out
too posed to me I want everyone to
understand this was my decision to
publicly address the post and apologize
I believe that is the right thing to do
Anheuser Busch said Carson King had
multiple social media posts that do not
align with our values as a brand or as a
company and will have no further
association with him we are honoring our
commitment by donating more than 350
thousand dollars to the University of
Iowa Hospitals and Clinics the contents
of the offensive post have not been
released the Des Moines Register reports
that the post compared black mothers to
gorillas and made light of black people
killed in the Holocaust
okay so let's take it for granted that
the posts are terrible he was 16 years
old a sophomore in high school he is
only now famous because he just gave a
million
he's not a wealthy dude he gave a
million dollars he received in donations
to cancer research and so he must be
canceled she just canceled the guy who
again is like lower middle class it
sounds like you canceled that guy for
the great crime of having risen to
public prominence on the back of doing
something incredible and you cancelled
him because of something he said in high
school when he was 16 years old guys
your standards garbage and you are
garbage frankly and if you're gonna
Moines Register and you reported on this
your garbage if you're a reporter who
decided this was newsworthy it's because
you're a garbage human being it is
simply not newsworthy and if you're
really concerned about this sort of
activity you know what you would have
done honestly you'd have gone to Carson
King and you would have said dude you
have these old social media posts you
might want it to leak them or you might
want to address them publicly but I'm
not gonna report on them because I don't
think that's fair but that's not what
happened it is gross it is disgusting it
is wrong but this is the world we live
in where as soon as someone reaches any
level of prominence they must be
cancelled if they have ever said a wrong
thing just despicable so this is the
timeline in which we live and it is okay
later today we'll have two more
additional hours of content with all the
breaking news and then we'll be back
here tomorrow with all of the breaking
news I promise you it's only a Wednesday
guys there's gonna be a lot of breaking
news president Trump sometime this week
will release the whistleblower
complaints news breaking hot and heavy
so keep it right here you're listening
to the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by mic core Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone is Andrew Klavan host of
the Andrew Klavan show and if only
Democrat congressman wily coyote had
listened to the Andrew Clavin show this
week he would have known that that Acme
impeachment plan was going to blow up in
his face
the Andrew Clavin show is where tomorrow
happens first so tune in I'm Andrew clay
[Music]